Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number remains 2192. David P, we've been
talking on the world famous bonus show lately
about what's going on with Netflix accounts.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: We make a little bit of money
on the bonus show. Sure. The big thing that's
happening with Netflix accounts is a crackdown.
No more sharing accounts between people who
don't live together. And I admitted I'm still
on my mommy's account. That's absolutely true. It
has all my preferences and my likes and dislikes,
and I've been on that account for, I don't
know, 20 years, and I'm going to stay on
it until they take it away from me. And
the eggman called in to weigh in on this.
Speaker 5: Hey, Dave. My daughter
turned 21 years old today.
Speaker 1: Happy birthday to her.
Speaker 5: Birthday present for
her. I told her she can remain on our
Netflix account for 30 more years.
Just like you and your family. Shalom, brother.
Speaker 1: Yep. That's absolutely right. I've
got my account on my mom's account, my
profile. My little brother has one as well,
and I'm sticking with it until Netflix takes
it away. And we will see how long that is. We
have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Ultra processed foods. What is that? What's
the difference between processed and ultra
processed? Well, we will talk about it. Ultra
processed foods may lead to cognitive decline,
says a new study. Is the study trustworthy? We
will discuss. We have really good news about
Salman Rushdie. He is back to a certain degree.
We're going to talk about it some some amazing
pictures of Salman Rushdie published in The New
Yorker. And we're going to talk about the
aftermath of that horrible, horrible attack
that he was the victim of. And lastly, the virus
threat is easing from COVID, but U.S. hospitals
are as full as they have ever been. Why? What is
the reason? While we're going to talk about it,
it's not from respiratory disease, it's from
other things. All of those stories and more are
on today's bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman dot
com. You will get instant access to the show. It's
really cheap to sign up, but I understand that
many folks would like a discount and I'm glad
to offer one. You can use the coupon code please
no more Trump. That's all one word. No spaces,
please. No more Trump. You can use that coupon
code to get a discount off of the cost of a
membership. And I want you to remember that
we continue the fight for 2 million YouTube
subscribers. You can help us for free by
signing up at YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. And by the way, voting you can only
do once if you have multiple Google accounts,
you can subscribe to the YouTube channel multiple
times. Perfectly legal carry lakes not coming
after you for it. Pillow's not coming after
you for it. Nobody's coming after you for it.
So just just mentioning it. Just mention we will
see you on the bonus show or otherwise back from.